all right what's wrong with you dude hey
but then draw me Cory says the pot
Monday yep Bahamas Baja Gracie Monday
everything puts a shirt off take shirt
after why you don't train a guy I'm
taking this off only details take it off
I'm not taking out because you're
telling to yes you are take it off now
listen you know you know better and I
want to eat some Korean noodles well I'm
drinking the some teenage come on I'm
gonna try Aventine yeah sure
take that jujitsu sweatshirt take off my
sweatshirt that I've earned never and I
want to take it I just rained take it
off when I take off of you well that
noise told me that no I I will [ __ ] I
almost gotten a mix up with you
yesterday
cuz we had some mats and I didn't want
to do in front of your friend I don't
care about my new friend I went no snows
you with you [ __ ] nose no nose I
had my shoes off he kept saying we're
nose no yaar we're on your friend Jeff
went you're definitely nose to know in
case you deny me by a nose hair and
you're not six-foot I am [ __ ] so close
to six feet that you should just five
minutes see of 510 no I'm not don't say
Papa you have a tape measure we do whoo
all right you ready yeah I'm gonna do it
my shoes off sure about time yeah baton
we can do mind you start this you don't
mind - yeah I'd like to hey take the
sweatshirt off before we do anything
else
I don't you embarrassing I was literally
gonna take it off yep because I'm hot
the only reason I'm taking this off take
it off the only reason I'm just H feel
better no take it off the only thing off
it's because I'm has their big logo on
the back yeah take it off and I'll take
it off when I want and if you don't
think that I flatten my neck out just a
little bit when I walk by guys in this
I'm sure
yeah because my neck on the right thing
Berlin sign goes there I burn my neck I
can do I can transition from a triangle
to an armbar to a lake you an omoplata
are you kidding me right now death are
you serious not a blue belt I am a loop
out I'm a hand so gray so really how
many years ago is that I'm not in my
[ __ ] I don't count to over 20 over 12
on dude I do when it's a 20-yard that's
for the Bluebell that's a [ __ ]
districts 2020 rain Rohan not go magna
at street sports for a long time
one's right ones last time you saw hens
are gracing rolled
the last time I rolled was literally
through two months ago
no I'm saying with hens okay see Hansol
Hansol just give me a year hand so is in
my heart
yep I always carry my hearty - I love
hens oh okay so how long my horse give
me like estimate I mean are we talking
telepathically because I watch his
videos I know I hear you yeah physical
running train in his Academy I am a
cyber student of hands with grace yes I
get that yeah last time you were there
go I suppose that is great to do that's
time we're at the studio physically in
the studio if you had to get out Sarah
may or may not have been a brown belt
here's the thing 99 me look it was
probably two thousand or maybe 99 yeah
take it off don't [ __ ] say that cuz I
want a surf and turf and I really do do
you know how Serpentor I really do now
or do i I tweaked my lower back on this
left side not afraid don't give a [ __ ]
anyway I'll still go this whiskey so
nice the whiskey she calms me down so
you're lucky you lucky is that nice
we're gonna have another match and if
you're ready we're gonna do it and we're
we're in in that span I know we have
access to mats yep you took your time
tell you this you know what about you
know better pub I'll put it back on nope
could you be really hot if you didn't
listen me look at me we're gonna go take
downs where I have room sure and I know
you're gonna do that stupid [ __ ]
double leg but I see it coming
no don't won't do a double a good oh
good luck that what are you gonna do hip
toss me good [ __ ] luck nope single
leg single leg on me we do not clear
this out right now keep talking [ __ ] and
take you down
listenmi listenmi I'm telling you I
don't have room to move here did we do I
have room in on Biggers but I don't have
room I'm gonna move this and I'm gonna
take you down I don't have room to move
dude I'm telling right if you talking
chill it's gonna happen on Monday what
it's gonna happen on Monday
what's gonna happen on Monday today's
Monday but yeah I'm not afraid I this is
I don't give a [ __ ] Monday to me now
listen listen up to measure me okay i'm
gonna measure me alright
and then watching I need you to watch
your movement accused watch your
movement I need you to watches right now
right
we're on turf I know that how do you
keep this attitude up we're gonna get on
sir I don't know that you could
I don't you're gonna go you're gonna go
single leg
tell me how you want me to take you down
pick up take them you're gonna go single
I got me what would you like I mean you
want a dip you are what you want a trip
you're gonna a side trip nice trip full
I know let's measure I know you're
strong
sure let's measure you and then see what
happens
my single legs as good as your single in
my single leg defense all [ __ ] aside
it'll surprise you here's here's the
thing B it's Monday
yeah it's Monday I have a little whiskey
me I've had a full bag of candy so
here's the thing you had a full bag and
I have nicotine in my look here's the
thing dude so you're under the influence
right now not really
we're gonna move this table I'll let you
start with a however deep you want to
get on a single leg and we'll see how it
goes for you yeah and then what are you
gonna do wait hold on I'm not sure all
right
[Applause]
sorry like tense right now just a little
tense cuz we don't we don't really
[ __ ] you know when things are do it
to you we got some quarantine I got my
testosterone is can you imagine when I
go on tests what is gonna happen your
face well that's gonna happen to your
hair that's not cool it makes you more
bald you know that that's the problem
that's the other reason that I want to
go on tests I mean
but I get sore and it takes me a while
to recover I notice our own can help but
that I think right I guess so can human
growth so can [ __ ] me help takes a while
to work the thing but also testosterone
your hair just you know what the problem
with test and anavar and human growth
for a guy like Brian what you'd be so a
thin man yeah you'd be you'd be a thick
thick shredded think I met daddy your
fear oh cool you're honorable man hey
daddy your feet your uncle man what
about my feet dude like your uncle I got
long toes I can throw on the [ __ ]
animal a with my feet now now take care
of myself you know what I mean now I'll
go turf I'll go surf whatever it is I
mean I'm saying it's still a coat hanger
now I'm still totally sure and and
sinewy like a parkour athlete do you
know what I'm saying you guys know what
the [ __ ] I'm saying certain things are
for us are this you're never gonna
ripple and I'm never gonna be skinned be
quiet fat yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]